bill dana for more on this let's bring
in art del cuento he's the vice
president of the national border patrol
council one of those record numbers
includes
unaccompanied minors picked up at
the border another record broken art
no that definitely it's i mean it's
overwhelming a lot of what's happening
and the cartels the drug smugglers
they know about this so they purposely
send big groups across
knowing that agents are going to be
distracted knowing that agents are going
to be pulled from certain areas of the
line
so they can have to process all the
while they're bringing their drugs
across
and something needs to be done by this
administration to stop it
you know you hear uh words of you know
hey they've waved the white flag
i can tell you you know from speaking to
agents on the ground none of us the
agents out there waving the white flag
we're americans we're not going to wave
the white flag we're not going to give
up our border that's our nation's
borders
they're out there doing a job and
they'll continue to do the job but it is
very frustrating when you have the
agency
heads and an administration that is not
backing them up right now all right so
we just talked about record numbers
today is august 3rd
take a listen to what vice president
kamala harris said back on
june 25th i call it progress
we're not exactly where we want to be
yet but we have seen extreme progress
over these last few months
because of his dedication and his
efforts
has there been progress
i mean if what they mean by progress is
allowing people to enter and break our
laws and i guess
you know in their eyes that's progress
but realistically there's been no
progress
and look i've said it many times i don't
care if you're on the right side or
the left side of the aisle we all
deserve to be safe in our homes
there should be no difference when it
comes to our nation's borders and right
now
it's beyond chaotic it's horrific
with these individuals that are coming
across and you you look at the numbers
of the apprehensions
but what you've got to look at is those
apprehensions are being released in the
united states
and then you have the covet talk many
times individuals that are being
arrested
they get sent to other organizations and
detention facilities
later after they've been there for a
while agents get the call and say hey
so and so that you arrested several days
ago ended up being positive for covid
so it's it's a domino effect that just
there is no end in sight right now
unless you go back to the policies that
worked
under the last administration the remain
in mexico was the humane way to do
things
because it it fast-tracked those that
had real asylum claims
and at the same time it discouraged all
the people that are
coming across right now finding those
loopholes in our immigration system to
your point about covet cases in the rio
grande valley
um 135 detainees tested positive for the
first two weeks of july
that's a 900 increase compared to
previous 14 months
and now with the delta variant uh you
could imagine that that's going to be
even higher so a lot to a lot to deal
with here art we appreciate you coming
on
we'll stay in touch with you thank you
thank you